uh
all right um
I would have normally said she can't
need some introducing but given he's
been introduced once he definitely needs
no more excuses okay
um
so the algorithm we discussed was
take the
True Value
for that state alone
using
this algorithm
okay but as I mentioned before so Q is a
vector that is
s a dimension okay where uh s is the
size of the states or the state space
and the cardinality if it's the size and
the Cardinal is the action space okay so
what we want to do is we want to try to
approximate
Q
using a linear function approximation
okay and uh
so here Theta lives in some Dimension Rd
and this is what you want to learn and
this is a known feature vector
so since D is considered to be much much
I mean we choose these to be much much
smaller than S times a so that uh you
know learning this would be you know in
some sense much easier than you're just
even storing it would be much easier
right okay so uh
exciting proposed an algorithm for this
problem in 1988
and sickness
and Ben Roy
proved that that algorithm converges in
1997 or 98 I can't remember
and and using the techniques that we
learned this morning you can get finite
Time Performance bounds okay but what is
most interesting some people were asking
sir what is sort of the front pair of
research here one interesting question
is I mean of course you don't use linear
function approximation you use a neural
network to to approximate it and so in
some recent work
we have
sended this to
uh
neural networks where where this
approximation is done using neural
networks but I'm only going to talk
about the linear function approximation
case here but but more generally
so you might try to approximate it as
the output of a neural network with some
parameter W for example and you try to
learn the parameter let me just call it
data here too so try to learn the Theta
it's a non-linear function approximation
and for those of you who know about the
ntk analysis of neural networks it's
very closely related to the ntk analysis
the neural tangent kernel analysis
essentially tries to linearize this and
try to do something with it and so
that's basically how we can extend the
static list of Android approach to
neural networks but today I'm just going
to stick with the uh the scope my 2019
paper and just you know pretend to
obtain finite time okay
so this algorithm can also be thought of
as one step
gradient descent in the following sense
so minimize over Q
okay sorry
so you assume that the current estimate
of qk is going to be a is used to
evaluate the function at the state at
the next state S Prime
a prime and then for the current state
you pretend like I want to
learn learn what the Q function is so if
you differentiate this
[Music]
scalar
and then set Q equals q k of s a
then this is just gradient descent right
so you could understand this
so just as though you're doing one step
of gradient descent again changing the
objective next time to q k plus 1 and
doing one more step of gradient
descendants one seems like a silly
algorithm but remarkably it works and
this is what system Android approved
okay and so what what happens in the
case of function approximation
so the natural thing to do in the case
of function approximation would be
uh
we use this as the objective function
right so you have a current estimate for
Theta you believe that that estimate is
going to give you the value function for
the next
state state action pair but for the
current state action pair you're trying
to learn a new Theta
it's bizarre but this is what it is okay
and we'll see why this converges
okay so if you do that then your
algorithm naturally becomes Theta K plus
one it's Theta k
minus Epsilon k then I differentiate
this I get Theta K transpose
you say
minus r
Ama
between S Prime a prime then because I'm
differentiating with respect to Theta
I'll have a Phi yes
yes
it's essentially the same algorithms
here so you're using the temporal
difference
okay this is exactly q k minus r minus
gamma times this so this is the temporal
difference
foreign
your Theta in the direction of the
feature current feature Vector that's it
because you're trying to trying to find
a vector Theta before we were trying to
find we're trying to update one
coordinate a scalar quantity now we are
updating a vector quantity and what this
suggests is that you should move Theta
in the direction of the current feature
vector
okay that's clear
so in Vector form
as before okay first so I'm going to
define a matrix fee which consists of
the feature vectors written in row form
so each row is a feature vector
so this is uh S A
times B Matrix
I'm not uh like this you mean
everything
yes the whole thing the temporal
differences so it should be this should
be sa or essay
[Applause]
differentiate this
I would get the fear say will come out
right
yes
um
okay so in Vector form this whole thing
okay
ask you to believe me on this
foreign
yeah one step of reading the symptoms
interpret exactly as the same as TD is
one step of TD or is there is an
approximation of the TV out here what is
the connection between uh there is a
connection between the TD and the
algorithms and the one step of the
gradient is that I believe this is all
I'm saying is that this is this is the
TD algorithm and the TD algorithm can be
interpreted as well so there's a exactly
yeah because if you differentiate this
and set Q equals qk essay then it is the
previous value minus the gradient right
okay
just this one sign is
okay so there's this bootstrapping
aspect right right there's a board
striping aspect of basically we believe
that this one part of its character one
part of it is not correct it's kind of a
big heuristic that it's interesting that
it actually works and what why it works
it's not very surprising based on what
we learned this morning
okay
so the key idea
success
to
uh
foreign
but basically if you if you replace
these two quantities by the stationary
expectations
just exactly like we did in the morning
this becomes the part D pi and this is
Phi Theta and this is R minus gamma
times
P pi times Phi Theta so this is just the
P Pi operator
so this is that so there's a
deterministic system for Terminix
so the noise part of the analysis would
be exactly like I told you this morning
as long as we figured out what to do
with the deterministic point
okay so so let's see what what what this
I guess an answer this question what
does this try to solve okay so if you
look at the deterministic part
dude
system
algorithms
tries to
converge
at this point right fee
why
data equals
basically we try to set the smart equal
to zero if the system converges it'll
try to set Phi D byte if I take that
sorry
Phi transpose B pi Pi Theta will be
equal to Phi transpose to be Pi of P pi
over Theta okay
so we write it slightly
uh
so this can be written as theta equals
assuming this Matrix is invertible if it
is not invertible then there are other
tricks that contact play but I'm going
to assume it's invertible
foreign
both sides by 5
so this is what
I call this quantity Q hat because we're
trying to estimate Q hat Q as
Phi data
so it's we have a fixed Point equation
of this form
it looks very complicated but actually
it is not surprisingly
do it all it looks like this coming form
this quantity
is just nothing but if you're trying to
so does anybody recognize this project
yeah exactly this is the projection
suppose you're taking cue pack suppose
you take any vector and try to project
it so uh
so let me call out some Vector B
okay and it's not the language function
but
um
so if you want to protect a vector y
onto the space c what does this mean
basically you're trying to solve this
problem
foreign
trying to find some sort of a lower
dimensional particular function
so you can think of this as Q
equals a projection
onto this free space of
[Music]
this exponent equation
this morning
we did not have this
only additional thing we have is now Q
hat is protected so so having Q hat
equals T by Q hat you have q had equals
protection
foreign
because it's well known that the
projection operator is non-expensive
yes correct projection operator is
non-expensive this is contracted so
projection
p
5
if you have one
minus production
five two
in the same
to the Fine arm
is less than an important number of
times
so the rest of the proof is practically
identical I mean conversion minor
changes so both algorithms can be
thought of as trying to solve a fixed
Point equation with limited information
okay so both of the fixed Point
equations involve a probability
transition Matrix we just embedded in
the C pi and we don't know it so all we
are just doing is basically trying to
solve a fixed Point equation without
knowing that P but it doesn't really
matter both our fixed Point equations
and both are contraction
mappings with the same contraction
coefficient so pretty much the same
process
foreign
there are some differences of course
because the equations are different than
everything but but essentially
yeah so for other more complicated
parameterizations like you mentioned
neural networks right is there a way to
think of those is solving that there's a
fixed Point equation yes that's what we
did in our paper in this paper that I
mentioned with the semi-state Gene and
the email button what we did was uh
essentially
argue that it solves a linearized
version of the neural network
approximately
okay and then you have to look at the
error between the linearized version and
the true neural network and then and
then an extra electron would be the
ability of the neural network to
approximate any function in a certain
class and so on so it just adds more and
more error terms and more and more
complications and Analysis but the
spirit of it is very similar that's what
it is so it is a way to summarize that
like you're kind of changing which space
b you're projecting onto ish yes exactly
so neural networks are great because you
don't need to specify the uh fee right
ahead of time so to learn in some sense
uh the neural networking learns the
parameters three so that that brings in
some additional computational analysis
but that's basically what it is
the Q function the approximate view
function you get is no longer attainable
by the underlying but like it's not the
value of the underlying both so so the
overall error in your uh uh so so if you
want to
that's a good question so I think
so this morning we were trying to use
we're trying to get
error right now basically I'm trying to
get an error of this form data transfer
a minus three
Stars
we have three Theta star is the solution
to this fixed Point equation it's not
foreign
so this is uh
less than or equal to two times
okay we have categorized this
is just simply a projection here
so you have an addition here so
depending on how expressive you are
uh feature vectors are this error will
be small but now if you have a neural
network then they have much better
explosive capabilities and then so you
can try to reduce this and sort of
handcrafting the featured vectors neural
network will learn them free so but you
can try to characterize that narrative
using the simple NPK analysis
kernel but of course people say that
neurotangent kernel so completely
capture the full power of neural
networks so there's a lot of so if
you're looking for open problems so it's
very interesting to figure out you know
you know what can you learn through a
neural network so we have uh some
results using the NPK analysis whether
it is better than that
distribution
[Music]
well you can get a two-normal result by
getting it then you get a one over T
result instead of exponential result and
this is
key so
our T convergence into exponential
convergence yeah
can I think of this as well
goes to one this is
foreign
yeah I think so I think it's natural
because I think the error will have one
over one minus gamma and then to get
average cost results you'd have to
multiply by one minus gamma so I think
that will get absorbed
the projection of the neural network
like here you're saying you have a fixed
uh hyper plane that will just project
right so the neural network uh
foreign
[Music]
foreign
this would be a single hidden layer
neural network where the neurons are
represented by Sigma and uh and the
input is W so you pass it through
n neurons after uh doing some linear uh
by passing it through a weight w and
then taking linear combinations so what
you try to do I mean very vaguely is
you try to
be home
that your initialization for the neural
network is not changed very much by
neural network training okay you have to
prove all of this and then what you try
to do is you try to uh
foreign
[Music]
complexity aspect to it and also a space
complexity aspect of it in terms of the
number of neurosity
nobody has been able to show why depth
is useful
okay so you can do all the analysis for
multiple layers of course but but the
open problem is to figure out why does
adding more layers help in
representation Theory there is results
that say that from representing a
function point of view the number of
neurons that you require is is much
smaller if you if you use multiple
layers but from a
learning perspective why does it you
know how well you can approximate a
function through maybe in the center or
something like that it's still unknown
but essentially what I'm saying is that
when we do it for a neural network we
try to linearize the neural network and
try to show it in that linear space to
get an approximation but then try to
characterize the difference between the
linear approximation to the neural
network so you have to characterize all
of these electrons
any other questions
okay so now I'll try to move on to
how to uh use these principles to
actually find the optical box
so so far we've looked at TD learning uh
which means that you're trying to fix a
policy and trying to learn the value
function or the Q function associated
with the policy the Q functions also a
value functions just called straight
action language function
now I'm going to talk about how to find
the optimal purpose
but even here uh some of you are asking
me over lunch what are some interesting
operations one one
non-obvious thing still is you know what
happens with the neural network
especially with multiple layers
foreign
work on trying to approximate neural
networks using this thing called the
neural tangent kernel I I really find
the work my colleague what is the G and
tell guts to give a very nice analysis
which is what we sort of used uh
so this is just trying to understand
what is called European origin and then
what we did what we did was basically
put this and Incorporated with it
reinforcement that
uh so they did it for primarily for
classification problems whereas what we
have in the context of reinforcement of
learning is a regression problem we are
trying to approximate a function by this
Phi Theta it's not a app you're not
looking for trying to find the images a
cat or dogs it's not the output it's not
a binary label so you have to adapt this
word for regression problems and that's
great and then also incorporate it along
with this peak by the questions and so
on so this is basically work with
um
so this paper is sort of a combination
of this code 2019 paper with laying and
the G10 version
but single layer neural networks are I
mean work for multiple layers but as I
said really doesn't show that power
okay
so
um
to find the optimal policy of course you
have to try
foreign
operator which has a max set
right
so
um
the basic the algorithm then
is
spend too much time
thanks
foreign
don't take the next action actually that
you observe in your Trace if you
actually take the optimal action based
on the current Q function
motivation to use we call it a tilde
sensory
okay so here I need SK AK and SK plus
one I don't use a K plus when I do a
maximization here
okay
so this
by now the familiar technique that we've
been following
can be written as
so again if you're able to analyze the
deterministic system you can analyze the
stochastic system but now there's a
problem
there's a real problem here
because
this T is an infinity non-contraction
and it is not a
G by known contraction as I said before
so it's no longer compatible with the
quadratically opponent function that I
mentioned before
okay so that that is the problem here so
I haven't
seen this proof that I'm going to
mention now return anywhere so I'm going
to I'm teaching this class and we'll
make it part of my notes but I don't
think it's worth publishing we knew this
result when we wrote the 2019 paper but
it sort of seemed like a straightforward
extension of that so we've never
published it but I'll tell you what how
exactly
this way what is pi
you start with some so let's say you fix
a policy as before and you're just
observing Trace from that I don't need
to know the optimal policy give me any
policy that visits All State action
pairs
okay and then and then yeah so this is
okay
so t
that's the way I mentioned is an
infinity non-contraction
it is not a contraction
as far as I know everybody knows in any
other more
okay so this is not compatible with
what we did earlier so what do I do
what is interesting is for a
sufficiently large p
this is still the interaction
okay so the pain arm as we all know that
Infinity is not going to be approximated
by the Phenom the atmosphere large in a
large so for a sufficiently large P you
won't get the same gamma you've got a
slightly different gamma here okay uh um
Power one over the dimension of this or
something like that so so anyway so so
the idea is that you can you can
even though it's an infinity or
contraction it's also a pre-owned
contraction for the sufficiently large
tree
because in the difference between the
infinity norm and the clean R would be
something like FIFA or one over b or
something like that yeah so uh
the state is being generated by the
offline policy yeah now if you like so
then this key operator seems to be
different than the Bellman operator
because there you take the action a
Tilda and you go to the corresponding
stage I don't need to I'm just here I'm
just trying to learn the optimal
policies I'm trying to learn I'm just
giving it I'm given a trajectory so
you've taken your car whatever policy
you use your autonomous driving vehicle
I've driven it through the city and then
you want to figure out what the optimal
policy is so I don't know what the
optimal policy is I only have a trace
from from a specific policy that I'm
using despite that you can find that
your functions off you can find the
optimal pay function once you find the
option of your function like when I
mentioned then you just have if I figure
out Q then I just get
I just need to figure out the true Cube
here I'm trying to learn the true Cube Q
star from a trace from a given policy pi
I'm not implementing this policy to
obtain the trace I've just given some
Trace
data driven decision processes the name
of the boot camp right so you're just
given some data from that I want to
learn that obviously
you can also try to implement it online
to some extent I think Sean's stock
would be somewhere like that where you
run an episode and then do it again and
do it again and then you're learning
from the policy that you're generating
along the path but that's not what I'm
doing here I'm just given one single
trace of that I'm trying to learn
something
right
yeah so this is true so the liapana
function that we use
in this case
which is this
okay so it's not the two Norm but the P
Norm
finite dimension of infinity notebook
production but it's not finite
dimensions
I mean at the proof is uh
what's this
less than or equal to
if this Dimension is d
and then this is
[Music]
right
so if I do one over p
okay close to one yes so there's it's a
contraction of this normal Cloud because
one over P for separation in the large
beta that is small enough
foreign
but if you remember
this morning
we did this
but also the other problem with using
the infinity Norm is not differentiable
so that's another issue
let's go for the camera
so this morning we did this
but I can't do this anymore because this
is not a quadratic so when I take the
second derivative position is no longer
the identity
right so you need some other trick
so this is a well-known
optimization theorist
turns out
the P Norm has something called the high
half of the pin on square has something
called the P minus one smoothness
property so what it means is that this
is
it's very straightforward to prove this
but it's an interesting property so you
can still
act as though you're doing a second
order Taylor series so the only thing
that matters here is less than or equal
it doesn't matter if it's equal to one
the smaller is equal to so now I have a
lesson about equal to everything else
okay so you can just essentially go
through the identical analysis that we
did this morning and uh
okay
yeah so the factor P shows up somewhere
the result yes the faculty which are
familiarism actually uh
my post office is typing all of this so
I don't know if it's useful I can put it
on there yeah
yeah so we can show you what exactly
yeah
any other questions
okay
so the rest of what I'm going to talk
about everything is pretty much open so
I'm going to tell you what is currently
known
quick question yes uh in this pin on the
projection is no longer a contraction
right I'm not so I'm going to talk about
that so this is this is for the tabular
queue language as I said everything else
Beyond this is there is a lot of open
issues here that I'm going to talk about
them yeah
foreign
okay
so the most natural thing to do
assume that the optimum of two function
is also linear like Q pi and then you do
this
foreign
States and so on so in general it
doesn't convert and you can try to do
simulations also it doesn't converge in
general
okay
so what to do about this is still I
would say somewhat open so what I'm
going to mention today is uh
an idea due to remaining videos
from 2008 or 2009 but it's
completely even more in terms of finite
time bounds and so on by xaiway Chen
you know to the atoms still suck
this is part of this reaction business
to
right now
yes yeah so do you have some intuition
for why it doesn't work basically it's
the mismatch of the Norms mathematically
it is why you can't move the movements I
don't remember how the counter example
works it's a somewhat involved from an
example but basically the the
so there is a production Norm here just
so so before I avoid it in the last when
you have tabular in the tabular setting
everything was I used the Phenom to work
here you cannot because here the
projection when you're basically trying
to project the Q function onto the space
of Phi you're using the
the natural Rod that comes up is the
tuna and this is not comparable with
that P Norm or the infrared norm and so
this enormous match basically makes the
convergence groups not work out but
that's not a good answer because that's
not that doesn't tell you why the
counter example works but I think the
counter example you have to go look at
where example it's that's like eight or
nine states and it's complicated but but
proof wise why it doesn't work is that
there are multiple Norms involved and we
were able to solve it in the tabular
case but but in this case the launch
don't match and so you can't get
contraction results very easily so when
you multiply the P Norm by the tool on
them together now it's no longer so
project before I had this property the
protection
Pi T5
is a contraction mapping because this is
a contraction in the Deep High norm and
this is also this is a non-expensive
it's a big panel now this is the
contraction in the infinity norm and
this is still a projection in some tool
on and restore an architect so the
counter example is set up so that I
don't know if the counter example is set
up like that I think the outer example
probably preceded all of these kind of
proofs but I don't know how I can't
remember the details where it's
concentrating all the examples yeah
but but at least I know from a proof
perspective it doesn't work because it's
incompatibility
foreign
so what works
reasonably well but still I think there
are probably
lots of dependence on this demon kind of
things in the in the finite time results
so I think that's probably something
worth looking at here
is that
okay
watching people do this in practice and
I don't think anybody understood why
they're doing this in practice but
this
I understood it by reading the Chen
Clark with the movie paper but I think
the original idea I think was underneath
so weirdly enough what you should do is
fix the Theta here only so there are two
status here one of them is fixed
okay fix it and then when the algorithm
for T time steps okay so let's say t
times steps the net for three times
steps
and then swap
the current value of theta k with Theta
bar so it's like a two time scale
algorithm so the bootstrapping that you
were talking about you don't bootstrap
you just fix it so it's a combination of
bootstrapping and there's one step where
you understand all of this
messes up the convergence groups it
turns out that if you do this
then you're just learning some arbitrary
thing here and then you show that slowly
somehow over time it's a very slow
convergence
if you do it this way in practice people
I don't know whether they wait this many
times in these in these papers suggest
and and uh one more thing in practice is
of course you are not doing this you're
using a neural network so so what they
do is that they use what is called a
Target neural network whose weights are
frozen for a certain amount of time and
then you try to learn the parameters of
another important using this so let's
think of this as a parameter to the
neural network you fix one neural
network you know the parameters of other
neural network take the parameters of
the other network and swap it out with
the first neural network parameters and
then again do this so this is this is
this is uh the improved to converge
I just
think
ing
of these steps and then swap
Gage did ahead to State okay and run it
against
and a few more tricks but the main
difference between earlier you were
changing it completely correct what
other tricks
are there's some truncation let's see
there's some Productions but those all
seem to be for proof reasons because
this seems to be more fundamental
because of this bootstrap you're trying
to you can constantly trying to
change what you're trying to seek here
and that's what makes the problem
difficult
the one step of gradient descent doesn't
make complete sense right because you're
changing the optimization objective each
time uh here you're not doing that
yeah
so if that makes sense to think of this
this sort of a solving
a little fixed Point problems with
respective exactly exactly yeah that's
exactly so you're trying to learn
something fixed here not not not uh
you're trying to find this to match R
minus something fixed no longer the
original at this point but it's not even
a fixed Point equation because this is
not equal to this thing we're not trying
to set this equal to this if I accept
that equal to this in some very slow
types here
so we're trying to set this stick within
this but here it's no longer has data
cases no longer has a fixed point and
multiplication just some equation we're
trying to solve something convex New
Edition actually
um I guess yeah because you just think
of this this minus this way
without bootstrapping basically yeah
so
um maybe it doesn't work in practice but
uh theoretically if it's just one step
of creating the same let's say you did
one set of the redesign or something
like that that's like compatible with
the Phenom does everything check out
in a slightly different context yeah and
I don't know if
there's a compatible
fragment Divergence from which this will
work it's an interesting question
what is that
so you do finite time balance it that
Bond will depend on t i c so it's a
parameter okay
foreign
okay
suppose
that's a good question it might be that
might be right so it might depend on the
problem what the t is yeah that's what I
mean so I don't think these results are
I would say
I like it a lot but I think they're
probably still a lot more work
I think a lot of problems different
parameters
okay so Q learning can be thought of as
an alternative to
values Direction value iteration tries
to solve Q equals TQ right instead what
key learning and TD learning all of
these things do is that they look at the
difference Q minus TQ for approximate PQ
because we don't know the probability
transition Matrix the adap whatever
parameters you're trying to learn by
looking at this difference right this
temporal methods
the entirely different set of algorithms
can be obtained from the policy
information
so um
so fix the policy pi
Qi so let me call it i k
okay fix the policy Pi k get the Q
function associated with that function
5K how would you do it using T here
this right now we have a new policy okay
so now you can pay
you
bye okay
goodbye
is that a new policy this is what Wayne
I mentioned this morning so this is
policy iteration back and forth
right
but the problem with this is that this
will not work in the setting where you
don't know the probability transition
matrices because the optimal policy here
could be deterministic
so for each action for each state you
might take the particular action whereas
to learn the true Q function to be able
to do this you need to be able to visit
all state action pairs
so what you do
you know in a reinforcement learning
setup is still do the first steps pixel
5 gauge learn Q by K with the without
function approximation using TDI
and then your new policy Pi K plus 1
is a software version of this policy
what do I mean by that
foreign
so this is just a soft Max version of
control maximum anybody understand this
so the the larger the beta is you put
all your weight on the action that
maximizes Q by let's say
thank you
so this is
a great enforcement learning version of
policy iteration is actually this is
called natural policy grade
so nothing about various dissect here
but but it's a regularly the kind of
yeah it is actually this turns out to be
policy gradient actually it is a
gradient percent with a
negative mirror the same kind of thing
with the KL
penalty so you do that and then if you
just cleanly write it in responsible
people might see this in lots of other
contexts this kind of thing so it's
called natural policy gradient because
it's derived from a positive radius from
a very interesting perspective which
with the breckman appropriate Divergence
but after all that you can clean it up
and write it at this point
okay
so the only thing I'm going to mention
here is that there are not lots of
interesting this is a very very current
area of research there's been a lot of
work in the last couple of years
there's a very nice
long paper 60 70 page paper by
e
for sure
it's a 2020 paper exploring gradient
descent type of algorithms for finding
optimal policies
but the results they provide are not for
the last bit of it so what they do is
somewhere along the path they say that
you would find it will be very closer
optimal solution which which may be okay
in some optimization context but not so
great for for reinforces learning
context there is a recent paper by uh
by which
and my glory again
to
looks actually even the gymnastical
advance except that it has this demon
that we mentioned in the morning here so
even though it's function approximation
but you're wearing some models and
dependence on the state action layouts
in the box which is not desirable so I
think there's some interesting work to
be done here
the main thing I want to
mentioned here is okay so so we now know
of a fixed policy Pi we know how to how
to uh learn Q5 through function
approximation but how do you make sure
that this whole
[Music]
uh
then the up on our function
one uses in this case Okay so so what
I'm saying is that let's say Q Pi K is
found exactly okay not using team
membership
exactly that I want to show you what the
app on our functions use to show the
convergence of itself
okay uh uh
Spider but in reality you get proper
finite time analysis you also have to
incorporate the 3D analysis that we've
been talking about only okay so you have
to incorporate use this lay Upon Our
function for the Outer Loop and then a
different way function for the inner
loop and together
okay so what is the reap on a function
here is a very nice the output function
s on her wallpaper
so it's a weighted KL distance
so for each state
there is a policy right there's a
randomized policy for each state which
uses the action so let's say five star
is the optimal policy or any policy it
doesn't matter if it's so this is the KL
distance between the optimal policy and
your policy
okay and it's weighted by something
which I call the tilde Pi star west
which is What's called the state
recitation probability
foreign
foreign
[Music]
Ty is a very interesting
awesome
probably
so what it is is look at the probability
of being a stated so down near some
initial condition okay so you're
starting the system let's say it's an
initial distribution okay the State
Reservation problem would be is just
basically this probability of being in
state s
umed over time
multiplication
so multiplied by gamma part T but of
course this whole thing when your mother
if you have to multiply by one minus 10
operations
so this is what the state information is
so it's a very nice example that
function that they use to show that that
so this shows that this is this
configuration is stable
um but uh but as I said this cannot be
evaluated exactly so you have to use
function approximation of something to
evaluate this so so we have to use
analysis that we did this morning at
early this afternoon along with this
function figures yes
[Music]
you know some steps of those radius
the same
for the for the PD for the first part of
it but not do it until convergence
sorry say that again so there are two
steps yeah there are two steps here yes
it's like
alternating minimization okay so the
first step
so so what I this this will involve so
you fix the policy by K and you have to
run an algorithm for a while here to get
the Q by case you know I guess the
question is suppose you terminate the
policy evaluation in the middle before
it's converted yeah yeah that's right so
so that answers will be in terms of how
when you're turning yeah let's do it so
so this part has two errors one is if
you don't run into Infinity there's
inherits and there is an error due to
the function approximation right so it
will be some of those two errors so that
will accumulate and you have to figure
out
so that's all in this paper so so there
is an issue because if you do this then
it's possible that Pi K of K given us
can get closer and closer to zero of
some actions so you can
you can't do that and so they do some
other trick to to accept the Stellar
open area I just wanted to give that a
high level outline so there are two
things that are very well known one is
why this converters if you know Q5 and I
know how qpi is can be estimated and I
can give you another Point putting those
two together is an interesting problem
and there is there are multiple results
along those lines but I think that's
more difficult
yeah so when this converges would it
converts to the optimal right yeah so
you can show that yeah it can so
okay so that's an interesting question
does it converged to the optimal pi
what you can what I can show is that the
value function associated with
Pi k
EPT on the value function associated
with any other part
that's capable the problem with this is
that the optimal policy may be
deterministic
and this is a randomized policy so it
will eventually go to the optimal policy
but I think there is some you have to
worry about the KL Divergence being
properly defined on the spaces and all
that but you can show the compared to
any other policy as eventually
yeah for linear approximation do we have
a similar projection so yeah so exactly
so this paper uses the linear
approximation part here
and the Spheres together which open
words but they also handle the fact that
some of these actions might
have very close to zero probabilities
and so you're not uh exploring the state
space very well so what they actually do
is that they use a fixed policy it's
kind of interest in the user fixed
policy
you know depending out
okay and they evaluate any other policy
5K using this fixed policy what does
this mean so you have to do a a
multiply by uh
some sort of an important sampling ratio
to to convert from the performance of
this policy to the performance of this
policy and that adds additional variance
and so you get a additional nascular
against drug because of that so these
are all interesting things to understand
whether there's a way to get around it
uh so is there do you have a sense of
like under what conditions you'd want to
do this policy iteration variant versus
like the argumentation area
I don't okay that's a very good question
um as I said both of them seem to have
stability issues in the sense that as I
said when I when you do pure learning
you have to use this thing called a
target a basic vanilla version of
learning does not work and so people use
in practice all of these algorithms
require a lot of tunings from what I
understand and and so some people
believe that policy iteration is more
robust
I don't know I mean
he said it was more robust but I know
exactly what sense but but it's a
interesting question so I think it's
like so historically policy iteration
when I was in grad school I was told
that people are just in the final number
of steps but of course each step would
take very very long time to evaluate the
policy right
but but uh so I don't know so that both
both have their own advantages
uh
I think that one thing though is that I
just value innovation relies on the
contraction property so gamma is close
to one I don't know if it will slow down
compared to policy iteration I'm not
sure these are all open questions I mean
if anybody can answer them
so if you're going to reach a certain
floor Beyond which is
at that point
use this analysis to figure out what
direction
I mean I guess in practice
now there's an interesting question what
happens if the state space is very very
large or instant actually so then
there's a question of stability the
system may not even be stable so if you
use a policy that's not stable then you
won't be able to actually evaluate its
value from General value functional
Infinity so what you do so as you're
running through this algorithm if at
some point you reach a unstable policy
would be good this is something I think
that the paper by Deva Bradford shopping
I'm not sure it's here
that sort of address this question so I
haven't looked at any carefully but
that's an interesting question what what
to do with mutually which occurs now in
the special case of Belle queue problems
there is a so you can parameterize it
within the class of linear readers you
know that people obviously is linear and
so there's this work by Miriam Plaza and
others where they prove that if you do
policy iteration within the class of
linear policies your components and it's
actually been extended to information
[Music]
but but not in the it's all in the case
Where You observe the state exactly
traditionally thinking they also allowed
for uh
imperfecting observation I don't think
that's good steady here but that becomes
a poem repeat certainly
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
actually if you're interested in gamma
equals 0.98
he said during training you should
choose gamak with a point nine or point
eight and this actually has better
generalization capabilities than
actually using the True Value
but that was I if I remember correctly
it was for a structured setup I think if
somebody asked of mourning that he's
trying to learn the probability
transition interest and then uh
learn the policy from there but that's a
that's a but but in his talk I remember
he said that in practice people always
use a smaller than drama for convergence
Readiness and then deployed for you know
but I don't know if there's a systematic
study
apparently
yes
okay well thank you